Let's go to our caller from the FORO for who's
calling today from 4 0 4.
Hey, David, it's Dustin from Atlanta.
Hey, Dustin.
Just hey, I just wanted your take on this.
So the whole never Biden crew.
I do get their sentiments, but I don't I can't
for the life of me.
And I know you feel similar to the.
Understand the logic behind that.
And I was just wondering if you could further
explain your thoughts, because I don't want
to feel like I'm the weird one for not voting
or for voting for Biden if it comes down to
that.
You know, so what you want to hear from me,
why I think it makes sense to vote Biden or
what I think is motivating the never Biden
people.
Just a little bit of both to share your take
on.
OK.
So the never Biden people fall into a few
different categories.
You've got never Biden people who are of the
mindset that if it's not someone has left
this, Bernie, they might as well let it be
another four years of Trump.
So there's folks that are sort of not really
making much of a distinction between Biden
and Trump saying if it's either of them, it's
basically the same thing.
I don't care.
I'm opting out, whatever.
So that's that's one group.
You've got another group that says, I would
conceivably vote for Biden, but I can't allow
my vote to be a blank check for the Democratic
Party.
So just because Bernie lost doesn't mean I
automatically go to Biden.
Biden needs to do do something either needs
to adopt some Bernie policy or reach out to
me in some way or something like that, because
they don't want the DNC to assume their vote
without having to actually work for it.
It is sort of another group.
Then you've also got, you know, kind of more
anarchistic types of the burn it all down
to build that back up mentality.
I don't think that's a predominant amount.
I also don't think that that's a strategy
that has really served us well in the past.
So for me, my approach is the following.
This is not about vote blue, no matter who.
And in fact, if we weren't talking about Biden
or Bernie versus Trump, but we were talking
about someone terrible, I wouldn't vote for
that person if the person was worse than Trump.
I wouldn't vote or I would vote for Trump.
We're dealing and we've been dealing for a
while, all with candidates who would be better
than Trump.
So for me, it's not about did Biden earn my
vote or whatever.
It's the choices are unless something completely
insane happens because of Corona virus, the
choices are Biden or Trump.
And Biden is clearly better.
Biden's better on Supreme Court justices.
Biden's better on taxes.
Biden's better on climate.
Biden.
Right.
So is Biden the most progressive guy?
Of course not.
But you're giving me a choice.
And there's no way that I can morally justified
taking any action that makes it more likely
Trump will be reelected.
That's my view.
OK.
Yeah.
Kids, I see.
I mean, a lot of Facebook groups.
You know, the Twitter.
Stuff about Bernie and the Facebook groups.
There's a large there's a large group of people
that feel feel the same way as the Knepper
Biden people.
I mean, it's it's really it's gotten extreme
the way I've seen it kind of.
Yeah.
Manifest.
The only thing I disagree with you, the one
thing I would say is in the same way that
Twitter and Reddit.
Overstated how much support Bernie was going
to have in the primary when that support we
saw topped out the Never Biden stuff is also
over-represented.
Now, the thing is you don't need that much
of it to help Trump because a lot of these
states are going to be very close.
So a little bit of never Biden stuff from
the left in Michigan could give Michigan to
Trump.
I don't want to pretend that it doesn't matter.
I just think it's important not to believe
that there's way more of that stuff than there
actually is, but there may well be enough
to give the election to Trump.
OK, well, thank you for taking my question,
David.
Thank you for calling in.
I appreciate hearing from you.